[Music]
Hey newly broke viewers want to get out
of the rat race and get rich doing it
my next guest book claims to have the
blueprint for living more and working
less it's called the 4-hour workweek
escape nine-to-five live anywhere and
join the new rich and it must be good
because it was number one on the New
York Times bestseller list for like
forever or like 15 damn months it makes
me sick to my stomach
hate you Tim Ferriss here's the author
he says hailed as I am failed so Tim the
title of your book promises a hell of a
lot makes me a little skeptical what is
a 4-hour workweek like how do you do
that where I looked at how companies
have two or three people could compete
with companies of two to three thousand
people and what I did is I just took
that and applied that to my personal
life and looked at case studies of
people who had reclaimed time using
relatively new tools for most people
that starts with cutting back on unpaid
overtime on the weekends and evenings
but there are some examples of people
who take it down to four hours but it's
certainly not something you do overnight
the buses don't respond well to that yes
I was just thinking I wanted to just
tell roger ailes that I was only going
to come in to Fox four hours a week and
then demand a raise but Tim you're
saying that problem now or more than you
do now yes Zach say I only really work
for 45 minutes and even then I'm so
stoned damn it's pathetic that I even
have a job now what is okay so what is
the first step in order to achieve this
extremely successful but highly
effortless lifestyle the the first step
really is looking at new measurements of
time and how you spend that time so
first of all I'd encourage everybody to
look at their hourly income instead of
their annual income because it's very
common that you might make $50,000 a
year get a raise to 55 but your workload
goes up 20% so you're actually getting
demoted overtime until you end up right
getting roughly the amount per hour of a
Burger King employee while you're
working as an investment banker which
seems to be the fashion at the moment so
a good way to approximate that is to
just take your annual income let's say
it's $50,000 cut off the last three
zeros and cut that in half you make $25
an hour so at that point if if you can
go to let's say ask Sunday there's
company called asks Sunday that will
route your calls from a new
number two India and let's just suppose
that you're a single mother and my son
wants the hot new toy of the season of
course you are
like the tickle-me-elmo yeah rather than
set spend your entire Saturday looking
for that toy you call us Sunday say
here's my zip code call every toy store
within ten-mile radius
reserved it for me call me when it's
ready and you save yourself five hours
so 125 dollars looks for two hours Tim
that may work if you want to Tickle Me
Elmo doll but I'm not that kind of sicko
you think I am you know it's funny I did
the little equation for Bill and it came
out to 37 cents an hour yeah actually
that was more than I made yeah Tim your
philosophy behind this book does it
matter more or less now that we're in a
recession I bet I can guess your answer
I would say that it matters more but
precisely because I think retirement is
in many respects a false idol when you
talk to whether it's dot-com
millionaires or middle-class people who
have retired you find that it really
doesn't redeem all of that waiting in
the deferred life plan so I think
reexamining time using tools to see
exactly how you spend your time like
rescue time calm or other free tools is
very important and that isn't coming
just from me it's coming from people
like the work family advisor to Al Gore
and Jack Welch it's coming from all
sides I think it's the perfect time to
re-examine your priorities and where
you're paying attention now you're a
best-selling author you speak at
countless firms so in order to sell your
philosophy which sounds inviting you
probably work 80 hours a week don't you
no I actually spend very little time
promoting the book and spend most of my
time working on either writing which is
something I enjoy or investing believe
it or not but the important point is not
being idle so I'm not proposing that
people lay on a beach rubbing cocoa
butter on their stomachs for the next 20
30 years okay just come out and ask me
and I'll be busy but go ahead is to
simply reclaim their time which is a
non-renewable resource
unlike income right and then to apply to
things that are important to them okay
now I read you
working on a pilot for the History
Channel you're plotting to break a land
speed record you're training for a
triathlon you're planning a flamenco
dancing trip to Madrid where do you find
time to perform open-heart surgery
that's what I want to know I'm working
on open-heart surgery but I have short
little hands and they're not very good
for reaching into the cavity that's too
bad because I do you have to stick to
your strengths I kick to your strengths
I gotcha I don't have any strength
that's my problem
Tim Farriss congratulations on the
phenomenal success of your book like I
said I hate you for that and but anyway
it I'm gonna do I'm gonna read it when I
get home the book is called the 4-hour
workweek escape nine-to-five live
anywhere and join the new rich thank you
we'll close things out with the